China's president officially won a new
term in office overnight ending the
twice a decade Communist Party Congress
President Xi Jinping's name and
political ideology are now written into
the party's Constitution that makes Xi
Jingping the country's most powerful
leader since Mao Zedong founder of the
People's Republic Ben Tracy is in
Beijing then good morning good morning
so Xi Jinping does not yet have a little
red book like Chairman Mao did with his
thoughts on governing and life but
shooting things ideas will now be taught
in Chinese schools and challenging him
is considered challenging Communist
Party rule when President Xi revealed
the new leaders of China's Communist
Party today there was no obvious
successor fueling speculation that he
will try to stay in power indefinitely
she has been making the case that China
needs a steady hand to continue to grow
its economy build its military and
become a global superpower state media
is rapidly building a cult of
personality around its leader drawing
comparisons to the larger-than-life
Chairman Mao that Communist Party has
taken over nearly all of the billboards
in Beijing and large red banners above
the freeways proclaims Xi's new era and
the Communist Party is doubling down on
propaganda turning villages like this
outside of Beijing into commercials for
the party complete with a giant TV
screen just to make sure everyone gets
the message in the past five years Xi
Jinping has remade China in his image
sidelined or jailed many of his rivals
and crackdown on public dissent and what
Xi Jinping has tried to do is to put the
Commons party back into the center of
Chinese political life and to impose
much more control and what party members
and citizens in general say do and
ultimately think as well
when President Trump comes to Beijing
next month he is expected to press
President Xi on issues like trade and
North Korea but unlike mr. Trump who
needs support from Congress president
she now has unilateral decision making
Authority a big story Ben Tracy and
Beijing thank you